من حواره جنوبيه نابلس مراسله الجزيره
جيفارا البديري تنضم الينا جيفارا كيف
يبدو المشهد في ظل كل هذه الاجراءات
الاسرائيليه وعاقبه كل هذه ايضا الممارسات
التي تمت من المستوطنين
الوضع هنا في بلده حواره وكانه اشبه بمنع
تجول بالكامل قوات الاحتلال رغم انها لا
تتواجد بكثافه الا انها تتواجد بين الازقه
والحارات هنا في داخل هذه البلده التي هي
اصلا توصل جنوب نابلس بكل وسط وجنوب الضفه
الغربيه نرى تواجد لقوات الاحتلال على
الشوارع الرئيسه ولكن وعلى اسطح بعض
المباني والمساكن وايضا كل المحال
التجاريه اجبرت على اغلاق ابوابها ولكن ما
يحدث مياده في اخر هذا الشارع هو الطريق
الموصل الى
مستوطنه يسار راينا عبر بعض المنصات
التابعه للمستوطنين بان هناك دعوات من
قبلهم لركوب حافلات والعوده مجددا هنا الى
بلده حواره وعلى ما يبدو رؤيتنا قبل قليل
لقوات كبيره من الجيش
الاسرائيلي وقواتها الاحتلال في جيبات
عسكريه كانت تسرع الى الدوار الرئيسي اخر
هذا الشارع يبدو انه اما لمحاوله منع
المستوطنين من الوصول مجددا الى هنا او في
محاوله لحمايتهم ولكن ايضا قبل حوالي
النصف ساعه كان هنا وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي جالنت وتحدث الى الصحفيين بشكل
مقتضى قال في كلمه قصيره بانه يجب
للمستوطنين ان يتركوا الامر للجيش لان
هناك انتقادات واسعه جدا حتى في صفوف عدد
من قاده اسرائيل وايضا من كبار الصحفيين
من بان ما حدث هنا بالامس هو عباره عن
البعض بالمذبحه بالطبع كل ذلك جاءت
رماتيكيا بعد مقتل مستوطنين اسرائيليين
هنا وسط البلده في الشارع الرئيس في ساعات
العصر ولكن ما اكدته مصادر عده ان هذين
المستوطنين هما من ما يعرفون بمجموعه
شبيبه التلال وهم المستوطنون الاكثر تطرفا
في المستوطنات وبالطبع المستوطنات التي
تطوق نابلس من كافه الجهات هم مستوطنون
يعدون الاشرس والذين يواصلون اعتداءاتهم
راينا معكم في النشره السابقه كيف تمت حرق
عمليه حرق عدد كبير من المنازل 17 منزل
احرقت بالكامل اكثر من 30 سياره اكثر من
سياره ايضا تم احراقها شهيد وهو سامح اقطش
اذا كانت ليله عصيبه جدا هنا في حواره
والقرى القريبه كبورين وبيتا ولكن هنا
ايضا في بيت هناك دعوات الان للاهالي
بالتوجه الى الجبل جبل صبيح لان
المستوطنين وبحمايه وباعاز من وزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي
يعودون الكرم من جديد ليستولوا على هذه
التله رغم كل المحاولات الفلسطينيه على
مدار اشهر طويله بالتصدي للمستوطنين لعدم
اقامه بورا استيطانيه هناك ان حوار
الجنوبيه نابلس مراسله الجزيره جيفارا
البديري شكرا جزيلا لك